Dr. Zakya, another question of great
importance
regarding the fast in Ramadan.
Unfortunately, there are many brothers
and sisters who neglect
the obligation of fasting during the
month of Ramadan. Can you give us some
words of advice and indeed from the
Quran and the Sunnah give us some proofs
of the fact that it is an obligation
upon the Muslim to fast in Ramadan.
>> There are many vers in the Quran as well
as many say hadith which very well
clarify that it is fur for the Muslims
who are supposed to fast that they
should fast it's a fur. We shall deal
with the details for whom it is a fur
inshallah tomorrow.
If you read the Quran, Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Bakar chapter number two
verse number 183,
"Oh you who believe,"
which means, "Oh you who believe,
fasting has been prescribed to you as it
was prescribed to people who came before
you, so that you may learn self-esteem."
Here the Arabic word used is kba. Kutba
means prescribed.
It is written amongst the other things
which are compulsory. It has been
prescribed. It has been made compulsory
for you also. Fasting as it was made
compulsory for people who came before
you. That means it was compulsory even
for people that came before the Jews,
the Christian etc. But it's also made
compulsory for the Muslims.
for the believers and further it says
point number one it's compulsory for you
point number two it's compulsory for
people who came before you point number
three
so that you may learn self-restraint
is derived from the word same as the
root word for tawa
which means that you have to fear
yourself you know from of Allah in short
the meaning of the word tawa it is
somewhat like god consciousness means
piety means righteousness. So here Allah
is telling fasting has been prescribed
to you so that you may learn
self-restraint
so that learn tawa you increase yourself
in tawa in god consciousness in
righteousness in piety and when a person
fasts
what happens that he feels hungry
and normally when a person is wellfed
that gives him more energy to many a
times do things which are also
prohibited and to commit sins. The
moment you fast your action towards
things which are prohibited goes down
and the barometer of tawa goes high.
That is the reason fasting helps you to
improve your self-restraint increase
your tawa level.
Furthermore it's mentioned in the Quran
in surah bakar chapter number two verse
number 185 Allah says
that Ramadan was the month in which the
Quran was revealed as a guidance to
humankind
and it assigns
for guidance and judgment between right
and wrong. Immediately after that Allah
says the people who witness this month
they should fast. They again become the
for the Muslims that if you in this
month of Ramadan you should fast and it
gives exceptions that if you are ill or
if you're traveling then the period can
be made later on etc. But here this
verse says it is compulsory for every
Muslim to fast in the month of Ramadan
and the exceptions are there.
Furthermore, there are several say a
hadith which make it compulsory for the
Muslim to fast. I'll just quote one
which is the most important one. A
beloved prophet wasallam he said it's
mentioned in say bkari volume number one
in the book of iman hadith number eight
our beloved prophet said that Islam is
based on five pillars. The first
isahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
there's no god and prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is the messenger of
Allah the second is establishing prayers
the third is giving zakat that's
obligated charity
the fourth is performing hajj that the
pilgrimage to the holy city of Makkah
and the fifth
is observing ps that is fasting so from
this hadith of say bkari volume number
one in the book of Ian had number eight
it says that fasting is one of the
pillars of Islam not only is it fur it
is one of the principles one of the
pillars of Islam amongst the five most
important things for a Muslim one of
them is fasting
so from these evidence we come to know
that fasting is fur for every Muslim
>> well I don't think it can be put in much
of a clearer Okay. To be honest, I think
that people should take advice and fast
this Ramadan.